it's Wednesday September 28 and you're
watching gamespot news I'm Jake filling
him for Justin who was supposed to fill
in for Mary who was supposed to fill in
for Rob who was supposed to fill in for
Jess let's get going just when you
thought there couldn't be any more
Pokemon go news I'm here to bring you
more Pokemon go news dozens of people
have filed complaints with the Federal
Trade Commission about Pokemon go
including one person who says they
nearly killed a child with their car in
part because of the game records
obtained by polygons Freedom of
Information Act request show that there
have been 72 complaints to the FTC about
Pokemon go sentence record-setting
release in July 56 of these were
directed at developer niantic with most
of the rest pointed towards Nintendo and
the pokemon company however most of
these complaints don't involve
near-death experiences most have to do
with microtransactions one person said
they spent almost four hundred and fifty
dollars on the game but then lost access
to their account after niantic started
banning people who use third-party apps
and let players track Pokemon alright
now that we got that obligatory Pokemon
ghost story out of the way how about we
talk about some free games sony has
announced October 2016's lineup of
PlayStation Plus freebies for
PlayStation 4 playstation 3 and
playstation vita ps4 owners will be
getting resident evil and transformers
devastation ps3 owners will get from
dust and mad riders and finally those of
you that have a vita will get code
realize guardian of rebirth and actual
sunlight all of these games will go free
for PlayStation Plus subscribers next
Tuesday October third you have until
then to claim september's freebies which
include lords of the fallen and journey
if you don't have journey you should
probably go download that after this
video chances are you've probably
already forgotten about no man's sky but
not everyone has and some people are mad
who woulda guessed the UK's Advertising
Standards Authority is investigating no
man's sky after it received several
complaints about the games potentially
misleading advertising a representative
for the organization confirmed the
eurogamer that the investigation has
begun and is focused on no man's skies
page on Steam the ASA's stated ambition
is to act on complaints and proactively
take action against misleading harmful
or offensive advertisements according to
Eurogamer the
say has the authority tap offending ads
removed and blocked from appearing again
since the investigation into no man
skies ongoing the group could not offer
more specifics however it did confirm
that it reached out to developer hello
games and steam operator valve in an
attempt to get answers about no man
skies advertisements on Steam a person
on reddit claims they received the
response from the a-si regarding its
investigation into no man's sky among
the topics hello games in valve have
reportedly been asked to respond to our
videos that showed no man skies animal
and ship flying behavior flowing water
effects in large-scale space combat the
a-si is also apparently looking for
answers regarding the stated size of the
games creatures structures and buildings
seen in the screenshots before release
additionally the a-si has questions
about the quality of no man's sky
graphics as shown on the game steam page
compared to the launch version and it's
apparent references to a lack of loading
screens trading systems between stars
and factions vying over territory and
that's all I have for you today but be
sure to check back tomorrow for the
latest in gaming news